you picked up the guitar when you were
14 let's go back and one interesting
thing that just jumped out at me is he
said you learned how to practice in your
head because you only had 30 minutes
yeah your parents would only let you
practice for 30 minutes yeah I read
somewhere the call train did the same he
was not the practice part but he was
able to play instruments in his head mhm
as a way to like think through different
lines different
musical thoughts that kind of stuff I
just um maybe can you tell the story of
that yeah I just grew up in a
environment that was uh focused on
Academia yeah and I fell in love with
guitar and really just wanted the focus
to be that um so my limit was 30 minutes
a day for I don't even remember how many
times a week might have been every day
or 5 days a week whatever so your
parents didn't want you to play more
than that um no and so I just learned
how to visualize the fretboard in my
head and I'd practice all day in my head
it's kind of like you know the the The
Queen's Gambit the TV show with Ana
tayor joy and she just like sees it on
the ceiling I used to do that with the
fretboard yeah just practice and I
actually recommend it to every musician
because if you're just practicing here
uh you don't know what is more dominant
necessarily is it this or is it your
motor skills if you just take that away
and do it here you know you've got it m
so I'm glad that that happened and that
I learned how to do that and in terms of
like learning fast cuz like I had to
like learn how to well I had to try to
absorb a lot of information in a short
amount of time when I did have the
instrument I kind of would
like do things in bursts like even in
that half an hour I would just go like
play for a couple minutes and then I'd
stop for like a minute and then I do it
again and I noticed there was like a
huge difference between the first time
and the second time whereas if I just
kept repeating stuff it would be like
much slower what did you do in the in
that
minute just hang out just integrate like
yeah I just like my brain it's like my
brain was telling me like just chill out
for a sec that's enough information let
me let me take a second to integrate
that yeah that's what at least what it
felt like to me and the most hilarious
thing happened a couple months ago I
know you're friends with Andrew huberman
so he put out some clip which was a part
of one of his podcasts about learning
and he said that there was some research
done on learning fast and that if you
practice
something for you know a minute or so
and then you let your brain rest for 30
seconds or a minute that in that 30
seconds or a minute your brain does the
repetition 20 to 30 times faster and in
reverse and I was like whoa that's so
cool because that's what I used to do
when I was a kid like now there's
science that proves that which is really
cool from you know for musicians to know
that that that's a good way to practice
efficiently CU you know like some
musicians they're like practicing for
six seven eight hours a day I've never
done that I've never practiced more than
an hour a day even now like I've just
just that's my technique and it works
are you uh also practicing in your head
sometimes now I'm not practicing as much
I'm more always writing songs in my head
so that's why I like silence that's why
I love being in the empty hotel room and
being alone or you know songs come to me
while I'm showering or walking around
doing the dishes or
occasionally when I'm hanging out with
friends or like Comedians and people
just like say and I'll be like
that's a cool line just like J it down
my phone so it's not always musical it's
sometimes lyrical it's more lyrical than
musical now because it's like for me
it's
like there's so much music in the world
if I'm going to write a song I want I
want the song to be about something
interesting and so yeah the words matter
to me yeah and the right word
can can have so much power it's crazy
like we said with Leonard Cohen and then
they're often simple the really powerful
ones are simple and like you when you
mentioned Hallelujah you know he wrote
like 80 verses to Hallelujah before he
narrowed it down to like four and it
took him like 15 20 years to write that
song so some writers will do that like
and then other writers just vomited out
and it's and it's beautiful like I've
heard that Bob Dylan or JY Mitchell
they're like they're fast writers they
just kind just kind of comes out mhm
that makes me feel so good to know
lonard kohen wrote so many verses of
that like that that was uh that was so
deliberately crafted yeah extensively
rigorously
crafted he just would spend months and
years and constantly refining refining
do you have songs like that for yourself
or you fine for many years it's song
dependent some just flow out and it's
like oh there it is is M everything's
there and then other songs it's like you
might have started it with music and
there's some words that come out and
then trying to fill in the rest of the
words sometimes it can be like a square
peg and a round hole and other times
it's like oh no I can you know it it it
depends sometimes it becomes like a math
problem and hopefully it doesn't cuz you
just want to say what's right for the
song and usually when you you know write
it all together like the lyric and the
melody and the cha and everything's kind
of developing at once at least for the
first draft that's very very
helpful like sonheim used to write like
that just like he wouldn't move on until
like he would just go this way whereas
for me it's just like I'll just go with
what seems to be coming naturally and
I'll just let it be what it is and then
you come back and you say okay well what
what what do I have to do to this now
like what's needed